FUEL, PACK THE COURT AND PUT US
INTO BANKRUPTCY.
HERE TO EXPLAIN, GEORGIA
SENATOR DAVID PERDUE.
YOU KNOW, YOU GOT SO CLOSE, BUT
THIS -- THOSE ARE THE RULES --
TALK ABOUT THE GOVERNOR AND THE
SECRETARY OF STATE AND ALL THESE
VOTES WE ARE FINDING IN GEORGIA.
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, SEAN, I
HAVE TO TELL YOU, I THINK
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS EVERY RIGHT
TO DEMAND THAT EVERY LEGAL VOTE
BE COUNTED AND EVERY ILLEGAL
VOTE BE REMOVED AND THAT’S
WHAT’S AT STAKE HERE.
WE ARE IN THE FIGHT OF OUR LIVES
HERE.
THIS IS -- WE ARE THE LAST LINE
OF DEFENSE IN GEORGIA.
THAT’S WHAT MAKES EVERY VOTE
COUNT RIGHT NOW IN THIS.
IF WE WIN TORTURE, WE SAVE
AMERICA.
FRANKLY, THAT’S WHY YOU NEED
YOUR VIEWERS TO HELP US TO CHIP
IN A FEW BUCKS TO HELP US, RIGHT
NOW WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
TRYING TO FIND OUT.
WE JUST FOUND A FEW THOUSAND
VOTES THAT HAVE DISAPPEARED FOR
THE LAST WEEK AND A HALF THAT
YOU SHOWED UP AND NOW
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS WITHIN 10,000
VOTES OF BIDEN IN GEORGIA AND
I’M RIGHT NOW 10,000, EVEN OY
WON BY TWO POINTS, I’M STILL
ABOUT 10,000 VOTES AWAY FROM THE
50% MARGIN THAT YOU HAVE TO GET
IN GEORGIA OR GO INTO THIS NINE
WEEK RUNOFF.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, I LIVED FOR
YEARS IN GEORGIA.
I LOVE THE STATE, LOVE THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE, AND I
CANNOT BELIEVE WHAT’S UNFOLDING.
HOW IS IT EVEN POSSIBLE THAT
THIS COULD HAPPEN TWO WEEKS
AFTER AN ELECTION AND WHEN YOU
IDENTIFY THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
YOU AND YOUR OPPONENT AND WHAT
THESE TWO SENATE RACES MEAN, ARE
THE PEOPLE OF GEORGIA KEENLY
AWARE?
DID THEY UNDERSTAND HOW BIG THIS
IS?
THIS IS IT, ALL EYES ON GEORGIA?
>> WELL, KELLY LOEFFLER AND I
ARE THE REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES
FOR THESE TWO SEATS AND AS I
SAID THE MAJORITY COMES DOWN TO
THESE TWO SEATS.
IT’S OUR JOB TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE PEOPLE OF GEORGIA KNOW JUST
WHAT’S AT STAKE, BUT WE KNOW
WHAT THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO DO.
YOU’VE JUST HIGHLIGHTED MOST OF
IT BUT THEY WANT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS TO VOTE.
THEY WANT TO DEFUND THE POLICE,
THEY WANT TO TAKE AWAY OUR
PRIVATE HEALTH INSURANCE AND
THEY WANT TO STACK THE COURTS.
THAT’S NOT WHAT OUR GOVERNMENT
HAS ALWAYS BEEN ABOUT.
IT’S BEEN ABOUT CHECKS AND
BALANCES IN WHAT SCHUMER SAID
THE OTHER DAY THAT IF WE WOULD
NOT GEORGIA WOULD CHANGE
AMERICA, AOC SAID WE ARE ALL
ABOUT -- WE WANT TO WIN THOSE
TWO SEATS BECAUSE WE DO DO NOT W
TO NEGOTIATE.
SHE WANTS THE GREEN NEW DEAL.
WE’VE GOT TO MAKE SURE THE
PEOPLE IN GEORGIA TURN OUT
AGAIN.
WE’VE ALREADY BEATEN THE
DEMOCRATS, 52.5% OF GEORGIA
VOTERS REJECTED THIS LIBERAL
LEFT MOVE THAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
TRYING TO PERPETRATE AND I THINK
THAT’S A BIG SIGN THAT NOBODY IS
TALKING ABOUT.
>> Sean: I HOPE THE PEOPLE --
ARE YOU TALKING TO THE PEOPLE IN
GEORGIA, AND HOW ARE THEY
REACTING TO THIS UNFOLDING MASS
THERE AND DO THEY -- IN OTHER
WORDS, IS THERE A GROUNDSWELL OF
ANGER THAT IS GOING TO PUSH
PEOPLE TO THE POLLS, OR MAYBE
THEY THROW THEIR HANDS UP, WHY
BOTHER AFTER I’M WATCHING THIS
ADAM SCHIFF SHOW?
>> WELL, IT COULD GO EITHER WAY.
I THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF
VOTERS WERE TRUMPED VOTERS IN
GEORGIA WHO ARE DISHEARTENED,
THEY ARE ANGRY BECAUSE THEY
THINK THE PRESIDENT DID NOT GET
A FAIR SHAKE IN GEORGIA.
WE KNOW THERE ARE IN PROPRIETIES
IN GEORGIA AND THEY ARE BEING
INVESTIGATED RIGHT NOW.
WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO DO IS MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES FOR IMPROPRIETY
ARE NOT THERE WITH A JANUARY 5TH
ELECTION.
I MEAN, THIS IS WHAT -- WE’VE
GOT TO CONVINCE PEOPLE THAT
THEIR VOTE IS GOING TO BE
COUNTED AND IT’S GOING TO BE
ACCOUNTED FOR ACCURATELY.
AND SO THAT’S THE BIGGEST THING.
OUR JOB RIGHT NOW IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE BASE GETS OUT AND
VOTES AND KNOWS HOW IMPORTANT
THIS IS.
THIS IS THE FIGHT OF OUR LIVES,
SEAN.
AS YOU SAID OVER AND OVER THIS
WEEK IF WE LOSE THE SEATS, WE
MAY NOT GET ANOTHER SHOT AT THIS
BECAUSE SCHUMER WILL GET A
PERPETUAL MAJORITY AND WE WON’T
BE ABLE TO BREAK THROUGH THEIR
WHEN HE ADDS TWO NEW STATES AND
FOUR NEW DEMOCRATIC SEATS.
THIS IS THE FIGHT OF OUR LIVES
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE A BALANCED APPROACH TO
GOVERNMENT IN AMERICA.
>> Sean: SENATOR, I CANNOT
EVEN PUT ENOUGH EMPHASIS ON HOW
ACCURATE YOU ARE.